uh we are uh hearing from folks
in all sorts of different areas let's go
next
to richard from pueblo richard from
pueblo
hey man uh do you guys hear me yes i can
cool
hello hey dave big fan uh i have
one question and i'm not sure the other
two but they could be comments or
questions but
how's your day the day is going very
well yes
i just heard today that the u.n just
voted to decriminalize cannabis
i wanted to know your thoughts the u.n
voted to do it what does that mean
where does the u.n have jurisdiction uh
they from what marijuana moment.net
would say
is that they were making the claim that
it it's not a vote that like will change
the world
at the end of the day it's a vote that
will
be like a watershed moment did they vote
to recommend
countries decriminalize is that what
they did
i they use the term international
control
dot dot dot whatever that means okay
so i wanted to ask you when they say
international control does that mean
like
if you have a ship like a merck ship
going from
uk to us and i don't know it's carrying
cannabis
does someone from another country have
the right to stop that vote
or is it like
so here's what happened i just looked it
up the un
voted a u.n commission voted to remove
cannabis for medicinal purposes from a
category of the most dangerous drugs
which could clear the way to expand
research and medical use
they're based in vienna and include 53
member states
considered a series of recommendations
from the who
the most important part is removing
cannabis from schedule
4 of the 1961 single convention on
narcotics
experts say this will have no impact at
all on
international controls because
governments still have jurisdiction
but many countries look to global
conventions for guidance okay so
this doesn't do anything but it's a
signal from the un
that at this point they believe cannabis
for medical
shouldn't be classified as one of the
most dangerous drugs so this is a very
modest
change but not irrelevant and we should
still support it
all right i needed a second opinion
thank you staff also
um you i've called before on the show
and basis on uh
what if the dea could be performed so i
have to ask you a
a dumb question so don't laugh but the
the second question is if i i know got
the opportunity to
refer to da would you be my practice
press secretary
like on the job with you i would not no
that's not a job i'm interested in
oh sorry well i hope you think it's
better
all right richard from pueblo very very
good an unusual phone call and very uh
strange uh
audio uh tone there but uh
you know always interested in various
devices that people
sometimes use to call in